sprechen wir mal den heutigen tag durch
stoppen könnt also wir fangen jetzt
heute morgen an bei der familie jäger
mit einer wartung ok eine heizungsanlage
ja einschließlich warmwasser speichern
kein problem wir prüfen gasleitung so
gut wie das wird jedoch immer üblich
genau da habe ich termine vereinbart
zwischen 8 und 9 uhr ja als nächstes
zwischen 10 11 uhr haben wir fünf hier
bei der familie schirrmann okay für fand
ihren spielklassen zu tauschen
wir haben ja und der rest vom tag das
ist dann wahrscheinlich schon sehr
anstrengend bekommen könnte und stunde
länger werden bei der baustelle
himbergen 22 in dem badezimmer bei der
badsanierung die fußball c muss auch
fertig verlegt werden
okay und ich muss heute aber komplett ok
hat der erste schläger was mit der
unternehmen zu tun oder machen wir dass
das machen wir alles komplett alles
kleine ja wir brauchen einmal unser für
ventil
ja habe ich dann brauchen wir unseren
dichtungs sachs für die wartung und als
nächstes brauchen wir noch unsere
verschraubung für die fußbodenheizung
jetzt bitte einmal die waschmaschine mit
ja jetzt die schule und die überzieh
schuhe und jetzt haben wir noch den
messkopf den packe ich mach mir ein
warte ich
[Musik]